eugene levy catherine o'hara annie
murphy
daniel levy canada's golden comedy earns
five nominations in the tv categories
including best television series musical
or comedy the beloved series won best
comedy and dominated all four acting
categories at last year's emmys
and with each of its four main cast
members scoring a globe nomination
they could very well pull off another
sweep on february 28th
any idea of how you guys might celebrate
oh gosh i think well things just kind of
all fell into place for the emmys so
many of us were
already in toronto i feel like we're
going to end up doing what a bunch of us
thought we were going to do for the
emmys which is just be on our
couch in sweat
clothes but that's not stopping her
co-star dan levy from celebrating the
good news on twitter writing quote
thinking of all of the amazingly
talented people who helped make this
show
you did good team but he'll have to face
off against
another great canadian as donald
sutherland also scores a best supporting
actor nod for the hbo limited series the
undoing
in a statement he puts things simply
telling us quote
i'm thrilled just thrilled the same can
clearly be said for the flight attendant
star and first-time nominee kaylee cuoco
who calls this the highlight of her
entire career
and the great star nicholas holt is also
celebrating his first nod even carving
out some time from his at-home routine
to celebrate with carlos
i was in the kitchen doing like a little
like kitchen workout circuit
my phone started like going a bit mad
and i was like what's going on over
there
what was your first reaction when you
got the nomination when you heard
it's just so happy honestly i was like
um
have such a fun time on this show
obviously you know we're not gonna get
the typical golden globes party do you
think that you'll make plans
sort of celebrate online i don't really
know how this is going to work to be
honest with you but
i'll probably be sat exactly here
probably doing this meanwhile it's an
extra special day for anya taylor
joy who scores two acting nods one for
her tv role on the queen's gambit
and another on the film side for emma
olivia coleman is also seeing double
with a motion picture nod for the father
and a tv nod for the crown in fact the
royal drama leads among tv nominees this
year with six
including best tv drama jillian anderson
and helena bonham carter both score nods
for best supporting actress
while olivia faces off with emma corn
who plays the late princess diana
in the leading actress category the
first time nominee shared her reaction
in her instagram story along with a
shadow to her prince charles josh
o'connor
who also picks up a nod